Let's try and play with the
new Pongfinity racket case.
Yes, c'moon.
Good underspin!
Good for around the nets as well!
Next challenge is to play with two nets
on one and a half tables.
Let's go!
This is gonna take forever though.
Uuh nice one!
Good footwork training!
This isone of those challenges that we've
had it in mind for a long time
but we've sortof avoided it because
it seems like a bad idea.
That doesn't look so stable!
Controlled!
Seems like a bad idea.
Goodthat the table was there because otherwise I would
have slammed on the floor!
That was my roller skate celebration.
Yes!
Good Miikka we won!
Beautiful!
Thank you!
Next challengewe're gonna make a bouncy ball
out of rubber bands!
Firststage, the small bouncy ball.
Aah it goes so easily over!
Do your hardest smash!
That's quite scary!
Yeah.
Nice!
Ooh that's gonna be tough!
Should we make it bigger?
Let's make it bigger yeah.
So the final stage of therubber band ball.
Let's try, it's guite big if youcompare it to the racket size.
Ooh that sounded bad!
I thinkI heard a crack in my racket.
Yeah I  think that's enough with the giant ball.
It was fun to try out though!
It was interesting to try out but I'm not sure about the fun.
Last weekwe launched a new mobile game,
Pongfinity Duels!
Go and check it out, it's a really cool online
game where you can even challenge your friends.
Download it for free from the links
in the description.
Until next time!